if you've ever studied ancient egypt in
your history class then you are probably
familiar with the way they buried their
pharaohs when a king of egypt died their
body would be entombed in a huge
sarcophagus usually after being
mummified mummification was the process
that the ancient egyptians used to
preserve their dead safeguarding a
corpse with special chemicals and the
application of cloth almost like
bandages this was done to keep cadavers
from decaying usually because of the
belief that this would carry over into
the afterlife and it wasn't just the
egyptians that practice mummification
either mummies of human beings or
animals have been found on almost every
continent in the world sometimes a body
can even be accidentally mummified
through exposure to extreme cold lack of
oxygen or other environmental factors
that help keep the deceased preserved
fun fact the oldest recorded mummy isn't
even one left behind by the ancient
egyptians it is actually a naturally
mummified severed head estimated to be 6
000 years old it was unearthed in south
america in 1936.
yes corpse preservation techniques can
indeed be strange but none are stranger
than scp-1176
also known by the nickname the mellified
man now as you may have already pieced
together the mellified man is a
mummified corpse but not quite like the
ones you would expect to find buried in
the pyramids estimated by foundation
researchers to have been a man in his
mid-30s when he died
scp-1176 is a corpse that has degraded
so much over the centuries that it has
made dna examination impossible
according to some of the scp
foundation's best minds
scp-1176 is possibly of arabian ancestry
and thought to have passed away sometime
during either the 10th or the 11th
century's a.d
this is certainly not your ordinary
mummy and it definitely isn't like the
kind you'd see in a cheesy black and
white horror movie or on an old episode
of scooby-doo
scp-1176 is absolutely undoubtedly dead
by all clinical definitions it doesn't
show any signs of breathing and the
processes of blood circulation or
metabolism have long since stopped
however despite the decay suffered by
the rest of the body
scp-1176's brain seems to have remained
intact for almost 10 whole centuries
not just intact but active the
foundation's researchers have confirmed
that the brain has a constant level of
electrical activity consistent with
people experiencing stage 3 non-rapid
eye movement sleep known colloquially as
deep sleep so a mummy with an active
albeit dormant brain how does an ancient
culture manage to achieve preservation
like this alien technology cryogenic
sleep chambers suspended animation no
not quite
scp-1176 exists in its current state in
part because the body has been mellified
now this was a process a lot like
mummification but instead of wrapping
them in cloth a mellified man or a human
mummy confection was created by
submerging a dead body in honey
according to historical records elderly
men in arabic countries would sometimes
willingly volunteer themselves for this
process why because the goal was to turn
their bodies into a healing confection
in other words an elaborate sweet
delicacy created from a preserved corpse
that's right ancient cultures had candy
made from dead people all the
information the foundation has gathered
about scp-1176 seems to point to the
body being one such mellified man when
extracting the remaining bodily fluids
from the corpse instead of fighting
blood or other normal substances
foundation researchers discovered that
scp-1176 was full of a viscous
gold-colored liquid that they designated
as scp-1176-1
further testing of this fluid revealed
it to be you guessed it honey
specifically it was a type known as
clover honey made by a species called
the anatolian honeybee this stuff was
everywhere filling
scp-1176 entirely so much so that honey
was even coming out of the body's pores
this is due to the nature of the
mellification process typically before
death a person who had offered to
sacrifice their own body would stop
eating any food instead their diet would
consist solely of honey and nothing else
they would even bathe in it submerging
their entire body in the substance
inside and out until their sweat and
even their feces were pure honey this
honey-only diet would eventually kill
the donor and their corpse would be
placed in a stone coffin which was also
filled up with even more honey after
approximately 100 years what would be
left was human mummy confection a
honey-based candy of sorts that could be
then sold at street markets for a high
value price why was it so expensive well
not just because it was literally made
from a dead person but also because this
confection was believed to possess rare
and powerful healing properties
everything from the common cold to
broken bones was said to be cured by it
despite it leaking out of scp-1176
the honey doesn't seem to ever run out
even when tested under varying
conditions it seems like the mellified
man actively produces more of the sweet
golden substance acting as the source
rather than a container with a finite
amount and yes it is still edible after
several centuries in fact it contains an
abundance of essential vitamins and
nutrients according to the foundation's
testing the honey produced by scp-1176
can suppress the feeling of hunger for
up to 18 whole hours and there are no
long-term side effects for most that eat
it however this is not the case for
everyone the foundation has learned that
any person without the blood type a b
positive will have a severe allergic
reaction should they consume any of
scp-1176-1
the symptoms include acute humalosis
which means the red blood cells won't
break down properly and renal failure
which is when the kidneys stop
functioning this all results in death
for most of the subjects without a b
positive blood who were fed scp-1176-1
symptoms for these unlucky people were
the same as receiving an incompatible
blood type after a transfusion in 1985
the scp foundation launched a raid on a
facility in asmara eruptria which at the
time was owned by a group called the
mana charitable foundation agents had
been dispatched to this facility after
various rumors and reports that pointed
to this location being the source of a
strange honey substance this anomalous
liquid was being shipped to a number of
areas in ethiopia that had been stricken
with famine pretty easy to guess where
the mana charitable foundation got all
that honey right the problem was because
scp-1176-1 caused adverse effects on
people without a b positive blood a
considerable amount of civilians had
died from consuming it hence the scp
foundation was forced to step in when
scp-1176 was first uncovered the body
had been stored inside a large stone
sarcophagus as was part of the ancient
practice of creating a mellified man
there was also a copper pipe and spigot
installed by the mana charitable
foundation to extract the honey from
within the lids sides and inside of the
sarcophagus itself had a number of
egyptian hieroglyphics inscribed within
these were mostly spells and ceremonial
texts written as a way to protect the
individual that was to become the
mellified man there were also
inscriptions written in the dialect that
was an early precursor to the arabic
language however these sections had been
replaced with updated versions in
classical arabic one of these read
abdallah ibn salah ibn ayub
nasir fifteenth son of the great sheikh
illegible
was put to the fast of honey on the
first of rajab in the year of the hijrah
iii illegible and died on the 15th of
ramadan the great imam al-yasuf has
sealed him within the ancient vessel
marked with the signs decreed by the
ancients to ferment in honey for 100
years and bring aid to the people in
time of need much like a headstone used
to mark the grave of someone who has
passed the sarcophagus that
scp-1176 was in featured a passage
commemorating a man who gave his life
and body to heal others sounds nice
right but there was another inscription
written elsewhere on the stone
sarcophagus which translated a dire
warning beware imam for the mark of
iblis is upon this one according to the
rest of the second inscription the tomb
containing
scp-1176 had been opened before during a
time of great famine imam al-malik had
ordered it to be open so that
scp-1176-1 honey could be used to feed
the starving people jars upon jars were
filled with the anomalous golden liquid
and brought to the sheik the ruler of
the land as well as sent to the people
suffering from the lack of food however
the very next day a number of these
people fell ill stricken by a terrible
fever that ultimately claimed their
lives only the sheik his brothers and
his sons who had all eaten the honey
survived any others who hadn't been
killed by the fever accused the sheik
and his family of sorcery and these
surviving subjects attempted to destroy
the body that had produced this cursive
nectar but when the sheik's people found
the mellified man they witnessed in
horror as the body stood upright dancing
around as it screamed and taunted the
people al-malik declared that the devil
himself sent an evil spirit to corrupt
scp-1176
the honey confection was meant to be a
means of healing but it had been
corrupted the sarcophagus was then
sealed and the inscription on it
finished with the following caution to
any that found it may god strike down
any who would break these seals
countless centuries later once the scp
foundation had recovered
scp-1176 and the sarcophagus containing
it they began testing with the mellified
man their goal was to determine how much
of the
scp-1176-1 honey the ancient corpse
could produce perhaps in the hopes of
using this substance as a form of hunger
relieving field ration for their
operatives removing the body from its
sarcophagus foundation researchers
placed scp-1176 on a metal grate
designed to drain the honey as it was
produced instead of allowing it to build
up over the course of several hours more
and more honey seemed to be produced
beginning at a rate of almost a liter
per hour to almost 56 liters every hour
but then after 10 and a half hours of
producing what seemed like an endless
flow of honey something unexpected
happened the deceased body of the
mellified man dead for hundreds if not
thousands of years woke up foundation
staff detected a spike in brain activity
if you cast your mind back to earlier
you'll remember that
scp-1176's brain had managed to survive
and stay intact long after it should
have decayed the mellified man opened
his eyes and immediately started to
wildly flail around he made a number of
distressed sounds the long dead body
trying to crawl towards the outskirts of
the testing chamber thanks to so many of
its organs and muscles having withered
away over the years
scp-1176 was barely able to see or
understand its surroundings it couldn't
speak not properly anyway given that its
tongue had long since decayed the
foundation's personnel moved in to try
and restrain the ancient and now
animated body hoping to sedate it before
scp-1176 caused any lasting damage to
itself eventually staff were able to
force
scp-1176 back into its sarcophagus
slamming the stone lid back in place and
trapping it within they could hear the
once human creature screeching and
vocalizing from inside bashing against
the inside of the stone coffin with its
head and limbs it took three whole hours
of this for the mellified man to return
to its usual state by which time its
ancient bones were fractured beyond
repair
scp-1176 is a sad tale of a man who had
willingly given his life to be a source
of healing for people in need he allowed
himself to be mellified turning into a
confection that could bring an end to
famine and yet somehow this was
corrupted and turned into something that
spread fever and pestilence for now the
mellified man sleeps but his brain is
still alive inside while he might be
asleep he may never be able to rest now
go check out
scp-1461 house of the worm and how not
to kill an scp
remains of a chair for more anomalies
that prove the road to hell is paved
with good intentions